I worshiped Disney when I was younger
and still to this day you know High
School Musical and everything and and so
just to be on their on their network is
just a blessing and I'm thankful Selena
Gomez is thankful for her past but she
admits being part of the Disney Channel
family meant playing by their rules
because everything is
Selena opens up to Vanity Fair for their
annual Hollywood issue and while
discussing her Disney days on Wizards of
Waverly Place she says the company
forbid her from saying a specific phrase
quote I had to make sure not to say what
the hell in front of anyone okay let's
keep rolling with it so who's now 30
also addresses the struggle to shed her
Disney image telling the mag sometimes I
get triggered it's not that I'm ashamed
of my past I don't want to be who I was
I want to be who I am I'm at that age
where I feel like that's what matters is
making sure I'm healthy and people are
happy that I love since Wizards wrapped
up in 2012 Selena's built her own Empire
which includes music movies TV and
philanthropy I wanted to make something
that was transparent yet really classy
and very real to me but our girl Sal
well she's never too cool to embrace her
inner Alex Russo like when she teamed up
with her co-star Jennifer Stone to
recreate their iconic routine what's
that hat crazy funky junkie hat I'm
slept here inside me trying to look like
Keira Knightley but aside from all the
success sells amassed in her career
we're most impressed by her commitment
to giving back specifically to her rare
impact fund which benefits mental health
support and self-acceptance it's a topic
that was heavily addressed in Selena's
2022 documentary my mind and me whatever
you think you can't do just know that
there's no one that's going to tell you
no but yourself you have to continue to
do what you want my advice is to not be
afraid I never actually was afraid to to
tell people that I want to take time for
myself I never thought that was a bad
thing so to me sharing to be sharing
something honest and saying hey I'm
taking a break because I need it I'm
being honest and I think that's just who
I am
[Music]